the final story today
is that there is a rumor going around
that you can no longer say gay
in florida people are freaking out the
white house tweeted this
today conservative politicians in
florida advance legislation designed to
attack lgbtqi
plus kids
instead of making growing up harder for
young people potus is focused on keeping
schools open
and supporting students mental health
now uh what this is referring to
is this bill that is being pushed by
desantis that they're trying to get some
of this gender lunacy
out of the schools this has nothing to
do with you can't say gay this has
nothing to do with not treating anyone
equally under the law or anything else
but brad palumbo who's been on the show
and as a writer for washington examiner
he unpacked it a little more cleanly
that he tells us about the bill it
simply prohibits a school district from
encouraging classroom discussion about
sexual orientation or gender identity in
primary grade levels the proposed law
also specifies encouragement of
discussion on these topics that cannot
be done in a manner that is not age
appropriate or developmentally
appropriate for students importantly
this bill does not prohibit students
from having these discussions on their
own initiative discussions of sexuality
and gender identity simply can't be
forced by the schools now of course the
white house put our gay transportation
secretary pete
buddha judge out there to say how
homophobic this whole thing is
everyone's running around saying
desantis hates gay people all the usual
nonsense but literally this is just
about are we going to indoctrinate these
kids
in third fourth grade about issues that
let them talk about it in eighth ninth
grade perhaps or leave that to the
parents or home school or whatever else
uh john i suppose this doesn't surprise
you when they try to pass something
that's to stop lunacy that they get
called the bigots and the rest of it
yeah not at all i mean look they they'll
try to sell you this white house and and
the corporate media that pete
is the first senate confirmed to gain
cabinet level appointee that's not true
it was rick grinnell yep as acting dni
an ambassador to germany a very good
friend of mine and yours dave the
history
left leftist history corporate media
history has bypassed rick cornell and
and uh i know this doesn't surprise me i
think brad palumbo did a phenomenal job
of unpacking this he debunked
their entire argument far better than i
could the only last point i'll make is
to the last segment where's the downside
in not appointing 15 000 bureaucrats we
should see that as a
as a massive conservative win but now
this is just more lunacy you know what
it is desantis is doing so well and i'm
not a sick offender for anybody i'll
criticize anyone that's well documented
but
the old saying is true when you're
taking flack you're over the target and
when you're taking indiscriminate flat
you're over a very nervous target and
that's where desantis is right now they
don't have anything to throw at him so
they're rolling out the old he's a
racist he's homophobic he's a bigot
argument they're falling on deaf ears
they're not moving the political needle
i think if anything parents like carol
are going to read colombo's version of
events and it's only going to raise the
sanitary stock in their house
well carol take it away
so
you know it's funny and i know that you
three know this but i'm sort of the
squish in the room on trans stuff i
think conservatives aren't really
handling it the way that i would prefer
maybe that's a different conversation
but i think if you read this bill it's
specifically about grade school and i
think that you know i got all these
comments on twitter when i pointed out
that the media was following obviously
the don't say gay labeling of the
leftist groups the media literally runs
that in the headlines um i got all these
comments being like a high school gay
student gay student can't say that
they're get you know it's like people do
not understand what it's about at all um
i had a mom in staten island in brooklyn
which is a conservative part i'm sorry
staten island in new york a conservative
part of new york where her second grader
the they read this book called um you
know as an avocado a fruit or a
vegetable and it led to this whole
discussion about like can you change
your gender it's second grade like a
second grader is extremely susceptible
to outside opinion um and i think we
really don't realize that small kids
really do pick up a lot from their
teachers i did i read this bill it's
really short everybody should read it um
i don't understand
where in this bill it says you can say
gay it's about not discussing um sexual
orientation and straight is also a
sexual orientation so i don't get where
um that comes from i i genuinely don't
and again i am the squish on this call i
have had trans friends in my life i
think you know there are there is such a
thing as trans people um and a lot of it
is just i we just don't talk about it
the right way but for kids i think
there's a bright line and this bill
makes that line bright that's exactly
what it does and i have no problem with
it right so as far as where it comes
from i think where it comes from is sort
of what john just said which is if you
do anything against these people they'll
just say the horrible things about you i
saw all sorts of people saying well okay
now you can't come out of the closet if
you're in high school and of course
that's not true there's people were
saying oh they're gonna now they can
openly discriminate uh you know against
a third grader if he has two dads of
course that's not true it's all like
it's literally at every level nonsense
so dave this is all right
the bill specifies actually also it's
about fostering discussion so like if um
a teacher can actually say i'm gay i'm
married you know i'm a man married to a
man or a woman marital and that's fine
as long as you're then not like hey
second graders what do you think about
that like it's literally about fostering
discussion not about mentioning
anything to do with gay or trans or any
of it right and again the only reason
they're even doing something like this
is because these people have pushed all
of the gender identity confusion on
these kids in the first place and just
for the record i have no problem with
anyone that's trans you can live your
life however you want to live
but we can put that aside uh dave final
thought on all of this and then i'll let
you guys go and get prepared for a big
florida weekend i assume you all have
awesome things to do you know wrestling
alligators and things
from a media perspective is there
anything desantis should be doing
differently on this kind of stuff he
knows he's going to get hit on it that
we know they're going to lie we know
that biden will lie buddha judge will
lie the media will parrot it is there
anything else he can do on that front or
that we should do actually i would
yeah i mean i would this was this was
gonna be my angle too which is uh this
is a test for desantis and uh one that i
think i'm pretty sure he's going to pass
which is to say
that the trap that they're laying for
him is to get him to sort of you know
respond to this in a very defensive
mainstream
establishment gop way which is to say oh
no i'm gonna now spend you know a half
an hour talking about how much i love
trans people how much i love trans kids
but just this one thing is maybe going
too far
um i think the answer to that is you
know l-o-l-g-f
um
you know we we we've we've absolutely
had enough um i think it's it's it's
pretty funny that the same day that this
popped into the news
was the the uh it was the same day that
the department of energy goes and hires
a completely insane person yeah um who
was he was another one of these um uh
you know alphabet uh gender
uh uh crusaders who who you know
whatever likes to pretend to be a dog or
you know or or something like this we'll
let people google this on their own or
maybe not yeah yeah i mean i i think
that that people are now seeing that
we're dealing with utter depravity and
you know i mean let's just go and say it
these people are groomers
um the the obsession that the that that
these activists these gender activists
have with
children
you know at this age you know whatever
you know five through eight
and uh and and sexualizing them i mean
it's it's it's completely insane i think
it's uh it's it's not even a um
uh it's not even debatable what these
people are doing and and and what uh
what what they'd like to do and uh the
more that people see it i mean people
see what you know who are the craziest
people on on tick tock you know we have
the libs of tick tock account the
craziest people are the primary school
teachers